uh do you think do you think some people
are destined to be single or are people
supposed to be in relationships
i don't know that i think
i was just talking we literally just
did an episode of my podcast right
before this and we were talking about
that idea of is one better than the
other
should should we aspire to one
particular state
and we do live in a world culturally
societally where
it it still seems to be that
the undertone is still
why are you still single that carries it
carries that message that there's
somehow something wrong with you if you
are
and and i really worry about that
because i
i mean not least of which because i work
with literally thousands of women a
month
who are making bad decisions based on
that
idea of their value that they're somehow
not
as worthy or they haven't achieved
enough if they don't find themselves
in a relationship or they don't find
themselves with children and it
i you know i saw the the interview that
you guys did you and your dad with
russell brand
and there was a a moment in that
interview where your dad said something
that was
very interesting from my lens
because i have a different
i suppose just a dif i've had a
different
perspective for the last 15 years and he
said
you know he didn't feel that someone
could really
truly grow up unless they had children
yeah
which is obviously a bold statement
which your dad is not known for of
course
i i i am i heard that and i
and i actually intrinsically i
understood what was meant by it i
i i truly do
i come from the perspective where i've
i've dealt with
probably ironically as a as a man who
doesn't have children and who isn't a
woman
i have dealt with more
women than probably most people on earth
ever have or will who are grieving the
fact
that they have missed their moment to
have
their own biological children
and so i see the um i see the pain
the terrible terrible pain that comes
with that and i'm very close and
intimate with that
in my profession and i
also deal with an incredible number of
people who are made to
feel like a failure because they're not
in a relationship
and i think it's it's really really
damaging to people's
not only their confidence but their
ability to be happy with their current
lot
in life and and why what i don't like
about the cultural thing of
you know you're more successful if
you're in a relationship is that
i deal with people every day who become
instantly more successful the moment
they leave a relationship
because they shouldn't be in that
relationship it's toxic it's abusive
yeah they settled for something that's
far less than they deserve
and so success to me is leaving it's not
staying
but when we get constantly indoctrinated
with this idea that
that being in a relationship or having a
stereo stereotypical path in life
is success we start to make really bad
decisions
yeah i suppose it's an interesting
conversation as to whether there is just
whether there is just a higher like
there's a hierarchy where
you know there is an ultimate state that
is
just objectively better than the others
but um i don't know if thinking that way
does us any favors in our decision
making
in the moment yeah yeah i think you're
right
um how do you know when it's better to
leave
a relationship and deal with the
loneliness
of being alone how do you know when
that's a better option than
staying i
i suppose what we want to look at
is
am i basing
if we stay and we're really unhappy
then we must on some level
be basing that decision to stay
on the premise that this is going to
improve that this person is going to be
better
yes that this person or this situation
is going to change
and i said perhaps the most pertinent
question to ask ourselves is
on what evidence am i basing this on
this idea that it's going to change or
that this person is going
to change what is this based on
you know when a woman for example let's
take the scenario of
someone just broke your heart they just
decided
i don't want to be here anymore i'm out
and you didn't see it coming
but they left and then two weeks later
they come back and they say wait wait
wait i was all wrong i don't know what i
was thinking
i i i love you to pieces i i i want to
be in a relationship with you
okay maybe give him a chance let's say
it happens again a month later
and then they break up with you two
weeks later they come back oh my god i
made the biggest mistake
at that point it's actually really
important to ask the question of that
person in a
very sober way not in an emotionally
charged way
what is it that is going to be
different this time and why
like why would it be different this time
and
and i don't mean asking it from a place
of anger i mean
sincerely being curious what's the plan
here for more certainty because you seem
very uncertain
you seem to not know what you want and
from my vantage point it seems very
likely this is going to happen again
in the next three to six months so
what's different for you now other than
you got panicked
in the two weeks after you just did this
again
in a relationship where two people are
trying to make it work
you have to ask what evidence is there
for the fact that this is going to make
it work
it's going to work are we together in
therapy
are we working through it have we
genuinely made a plan about how we're
going to work through this issue
are we communicating and there's genuine
progress in the communication
because that's the part where
we consistently ignore the fact that we
haven't actually had any signs that this
is really going to change
and yet we go i just feel like it can be
better
based on what not based on them
based on whatever fantasy you're
constructing in your head about it
being better so it's can i live with
this the the key questions of these
can i live for the rest of my life in
this relationship
as it is today and experience a
wonderful life
and experience the happiness the peace
the joy that i want to experience
is that possible in my current
relationship
if nothing changed from the way it is
today and if the answer is no
the question to ask is so therefore it
needs to change or i need to leave
what evidence do i have that this is
going to change
and that's a question you have to ask
very very soberly there's a bias judge
in here that wants to do what's
comfortable not what's going to make you
happy
and you have to be very careful of not
listening to that judge